[Music]
rollin rollin rollin rollin rollin
rollin up in this hotel room [ __ ] is
[ __ ] goin telling Tony trim on the
beetus HP get King bats young chillin
chillin like a villain
relax abyssal Hotel auto-tune you know I
got a city
hahaha yeah
King bat here yeah oh when I take a [ __ ]
light a match
what a fun is as you work how'd it who
knew that [ __ ] could be defeated by
Mickey so cool yeah kill [ __ ] with my
matches kill the [ __ ] what a match they
call me King bats yeah took a [ __ ]
outside
oh let's didn't wanna line Oh burn down
the whole forest Oh burn down the whole
forest burn down the whole forest yeah
and now I started the force father
oh star the forest fire not a pause dine
normal paper everybody using iPads and
other all friends having fun sampler oh
no we meant to talk about Sam's how we
talk about ASA go to the promised I'd
get a fader hey talk about the magazine
getting the fader yo I don't get a say
give me the bland Caesar I'm not that
adventurous I might get apart yo I'll be
having sometimes that we liked my joke
conversation with my barber
yeah I mean like you I must be crazy I'm
gonna get crazy yo give me a part right
here right yeah you sure HB in
from Juba knowledge is keeping read I
think about getting graphics sometimes
really like the kids were doing like yet
like oh like I used to do kids the kids
do the little mazes on they said well
yeah you know I had that with the
Wolverine fade I called it I have one
line going all the way spiraling around
my head yeah I had sideburns back then
it even went through my sideburns that
she looks like damn let's talk about the
time where I try to hook you up with my
barber and he charged you
but as matched about I was when I was
out in LA I did a video of batch with
batch was a flamboyant Floyd Mayweather
type rock-paper-scissors champion okay
and I was the workmen kind of underdog
type a rock-paper-scissors person they
didn't take it that seriously this is
doing it for a job saw the video fun
time asked bats about a barber and yeah
I miss my guy here um this guy's cat on
Melrose and and then I I get the cut
which is it's objectively a great cut
he's a great really well done it's a
good haircut it was a tie my hair cut
all right you got you could tell you
some barbers to have you could with some
barbers with a barber is has the energy
of I'm famous too
yeah as he sure though by the way he's
the most what turn off the auto - he's a
mug
he's the most followed barber on
instagram because because of the videos
that I do with this lamb there you go
but every time he gives me a cut and
gilma shoutout yeah yeah and then now
he's almost at a million why he's always
at a million two more days over my
friend that's more than me I've had five
hundred four thousand that's only
recently since I've adjusted my strategy
but then so they seem like the from the
you know our discussion that the haircut
was going to be free but you know maybe
I messed up because I'm in my business
dealings I like to be honorable so I got
the haircut so I said what do I owe you
BAM because I expect him to be right
because y'all had shot us I thought he's
gonna say yo it's nothing it was nothing
he um yeah man he was like fifty dollars
or something and it was just where I
didn't if he was really wouldn't even
have brought cash with you that's told
me he took care of it didn't bring cash
good day sir yeah wait I said good day
sir
I could have pressed him I guess he got
face tattoos oh darling what next heck
no you know what it just didn't feel cuz
I was like I didn't know were the people
around there was a couple girls there it
was some oh no if they were chillin oh
if they were doing hair or hanging but
if it was just you and him would you
oppress him that wasn't the I don't that
was that they didn't influence it okay
it was just more of the dynamic of I
hadn't been in that situation before
where apparently my haircut was taken
care of but now is I just is it was just
one eye I'll just you know sometimes
others that this is different than
paying for something that you think it's
free but well my father's borrow money
sometimes and even I get it back in a
month or something mm-hmm and then then
you'll hear from and I guess I just paid
$500 to never talk to you again damn
that's a good way to look at damn
that's the deepest yeah but that's where
I sometimes or you could just never talk
to them again for free
exactly right but I mean the signal and
sometimes the in that situation what
about you Emily
he's like $50 in my hair mainland maybe
the haircuts are a hundred
they are they are hundred other haircuts
80 to 100 80 to 100 that sound like
almost sound like oh another booboo boy
huh I was going to clean my room until I
got huh I was happy to see spider-man
and MI guy in there thanks Renzo it was
that's the thing with movies is that it
take a year for them to come out oh how
long we like that shot that is late June
of last year about two weeks yeah yeah
it's always the shortest time around
I've had on a movie his neighbors too I
think we shot in September of 2015 and
it came out in March of last year so six
months is the shortest and so that's
what and so whenever I do a movie I'm
always thinking yo I could die before
this year that's a lot of time to die
live it I don't like this [ __ ] could I
could shocking that even they might have
to shoot around me I could die darkness
they might make this equal off of you
yeah like The Fast and Furious franchise
right I could die and [ __ ] you ever
leave like a song about me have you ever
forgotten that you were something's like
oh [ __ ] that's right I am in that yeah
god it's just weird if you're not
especially if you're in a in a bit bro
like was a lot of stuff I've done you
not as connected in the publicity
machine and everything so you're not
even with spider-man I knew I was in it
but I'm not gonna ask me I don't have to
go to the pond Jimmy Fallon to do spider
spider-man stuff I don't have to do
he'll look because if they got their
machines set up they get their main care
characters to push it so I don't have to
so it's kind of all your spider-man is
about to come out I mean that I'm in
that yeah so yeah you know you just kind
of disconnect from especially if you
just do two things
yeah I just did those to say and then
you go off this movie I'm working on now
I'm debating it's two months shooting
it's long days it's law eating this it's
funny man just even coming to LA can you
tell if a movie is going to be good or
not now since you've done so many like
the rotten tomato rating can you tell I
can't like just because a lot of stuff
I've done I don't see a lot of it so
it's just you know this is the first one
while I'm in most of the scenes and so
you don't know how to you know there
might it might be slow motion [ __ ] might
be shot action wise and so you're doing
stuff you might feel goofy as [ __ ]
yeah they might make it look cool so you
know it's a lot of or vice-versa over
nicer but just in general the process
working on a long shoot on a movie
people get cabin fever man I swear just
cuz I was coming here to LA for two days
for the show last night and people know
can everybody see the schedule or the
actors so on Monday people people with
other actors makeup people so I saw I
saw you leaving at 1:00 p.m. Friday what
you do what you want to yeah can you
take us with you anyway just because
everybody this long I was in it like
that you people what do you love to what
are you doing
what was your experience fella with
Marlon on if you say yeah improv the
whole thing really yeah they just let me
go oh wow yeah that's fun how many days
you work uh two days yeah we did a one
scene one day and then the bar scene the
next day but yeah it was fun I did
just going back on that same subject
unlike waiting for the movies to come
out
I found a movie last year I went to the
screening this year movie don't come out
till next year Valentine's Day right
because it's the Netflix like original
and they got day they backed up all the
way until next year yeah and so I
imagine this is you know you have to
deal with that process but for your
temperament with you come from the vine
world of just putting out just and now
into YouTube when is this [ __ ] cuz you
you produce all your stuff yeah yeah
yeah that's it is going from so I'm like
just upload it just do this I would put
it I'm gonna put it give me a later date
hahahaha so you started you started with
vine you started with vine that's how
you started poppin off right yeah well I
started started doing stand-up then I
stopped doing stand-up to like do the
the YouTube videos to get into acting
yeah then YouTube was costing way too
much money so I started doing vine was
doing I was it cost to what I was gonna
say was how I was spending like a twenty
to forty thousand video to dog dollars
on a video way in what year this was
2011-12 wait
your parents rich guys I tell everybody
in order to make a just that I have hard
work and like hard to launch a thousand
dollars the debate account to close out
of any production costs right because I
knew that only way I was going to make
it because everyone is are doing you
know it was it
so didn't choice on his part
and I could have been shopping at Target
he was going look everybody was already
doing YouTube videos I'm like I'm not
gonna stand out as my [ __ ] look way
better than their oh so it was all
production cause oh yeah oh and then you
switch the vine from that yeah okay and
then I went back to going back to doing
YouTube why did you
vine died by these wool vinyl advice
completely gone oh yeah it's deleted
oh it's deleted sweater delete is that
you can't pull up vine videos anymore no
they held it down and press next I'm up
there because I was looking I was trying
to fight because it was I was trying to
look at old vines the other night yeah
it's some but there's some other ones I
just delete is weird I did not I'm
totally out of the loop
sorry well the other respect yeah yeah
damn we got to we got to do a song oh
we're gonna do all the way too many
songs ha ha ha ha I love you ready for
this that's the just soul
vine was divine divine pickles were 2013
no 2012 220 yeah 14 they're like yeah 20
2012 20 like 15 I think that's what I
was I would you know I was watched by in
a lot and then I don't know I feel like
a like I don't get it no no it wasn't
that it was like I feel like a old man
well I don't know how to make good vines
but I will watch people but I remembered
your your was your first hit on vine
that backflip though that's when I had a
million followers yeah I was like my
celebration
he had this vine somebody lady was
getting arrived yeah and then you look
like you about to save it stays down a
robber and he just ran off the wall yeah
it seems like not far is like that
backflip yeah I was in the vine for a
little bit but I only have one vine that
hit and that was that was the one where
I got footage of you in New Orleans
doing the parade yeah that quick clip
got thousands of views and everything
else is like 200 views damn yeah people
I did this bit about my love for hanging
out in New Orleans because I found out
when I first time I visited New Orleans
in 2012
asking about things to do and somebody
say oh you should throw your own parade
through a second line they say you just
go to the police station get a parade
permit hire a band oh yeah I heard this
and this yeah and so I did the bit I did
the whole thing I actually did the whole
thing left for real yeah I've done it
multiple times at ham this is amazing
talked about him I said and then we do
another time we did it
Tony filmed a little bit of it on vine
and then it went online in people it's
real pops up you know like you're wasted
he actually do that [ __ ] yeah hahaha all
the comments like he didn't like his eye
glitter [ __ ] he's for real yeah we live
that shitty rap about that's just Oh
pops up like once in a while really yeah
like well not frequently but
occasionally I'll pop up like oh my god
it's true that's correct that's made
most of mine is it all real what about a
girl in the bar with the titty where you
told her uh to tell you the joke when
she told you to tell you a joke
come on funny mates must be funny tell
us oh no I'm gonna tell me just if you
tell me a joke I'll show my sis and I
said yo my jokes are better than your
test to happen oh boy yeah a lot of his
stories are true yeah I was crying you
know it was really that night well yeah
well I told her that because I was kind
of can we have been vibing yeah and this
was I think it was 2011 and I was I was
touring with Aziz I so I wasn't known on
the sly you maybe saw me right after the
show at the bar next to the show yeah
then maybe but we were at somewhere like
we was just kicking it mm-hmm and so
then when she went into that goofy jokes
[ __ ] I was genuine like this was upset
he was his you having such a great time
yeah and now you went with this [ __ ]
and I didn't I can't you know some
people can finesse those type of
situations you know I got friends my
buddy al Jackson he can just with
surgeons he can just make [ __ ] chill
yeah a lot of times once I feel
uncomfortable
I'm transferring that right / - yeah you
feel uncomfortable
you're right though l is like a good
energy of these like an energy sponge
you'll just take your negative energies
you know let's just uh y'all live better
like you just mellow shal filter so just
like a good person just a good just host
yeah yeah but that's what happened like
she said that's it now like I said yeah
you're my jokes are better than your
tits
oh my guys the war cuz it's like what
are you it's a great line cuz first of
all it's the thing it's really I don't
like that pressure
cuz a lot of my jokes told out of the
context of stand-up won't play yes but
did she have nice titties she was
beautiful she was beautiful and it was
going that was in DC that night was
going well yeah I remember this really
this [ __ ] is great cuz it was just a
bunch of beautiful professional black
chicks that I was running into and just
talking to good numbers and they didn't
know me for [ __ ] it was really a great
night in and I lost my phone at night so
uh any other women from if you remember
Wendy Z's I'm sorry recorded his Comedy
Central special it's 2011 you remember
that night you saw me and you're not a
lot of you probably have families now
and there's one there's one that didn't
if any of you met me that night and you
live in DC and you uh you still out
there I'm 34 and I've I've changed a
little bit I'm grown grown chillin man
oh yeah Mary's dot one thing I you know
we we met up a couple months ago mm-hmm
you got your offices and [ __ ] man got
office yeah
you can't got them office in the valley
nice like a big office space
oh yeah produces that Drake yeah what's
your output right now as far as our
lines oh um a video every week a video
every week mm-hmm
and what and a vlog almost every other
day what was the plan initially was a
plan from the beginning I want to be
funny and do L do did you because the
output and just the the connection is uh
is great to watch man so that you were
you like this is what I want to do this
is how I get there
no it was I wanted to uh at first I just
knew I wanted to do acting and then when
you come to Hollywood they quickly shut
down all your dreams yeah they just shut
it all down
so i'ma do my own [ __ ] yeah yeah I went
to an audition I remember I went to an
audition and they gave the role that I
auditioned to to uh it was like either
Don Cheadle or Marlon Wayans or someone
who didn't audition at all there's no
real uncle so yeah they were just yeah
getting the backup just in case the
offers didn't yeah yeah so I realized I
was like oh
y'all gonna treat me like the side [ __ ]
okay they're getting the roles because
they famous I need to make myself I get
I got to give myself a name so I was
like alright let me create a like a demo
reel just like show producers and
directors and casting directors and
knowledge and all that and in doing that
I started to create like a fan base
online yeah very smart and then I was
out [ __ ]
well I might as well just keep going
with it and then it went from like I
remembered 3,000 followers subscribers
to like 25,000 subscribers turned into
like a hundred thousand and just what a
what number did you turn your
notifications up uh when I got to like a
million yeah yeah oh sit so you would
deep connected for a while oh yeah I was
connected in messaging back mm-hmm yeah
yeah and I would and even on my other
tell my other platforms I don't have
lot of subscribers I'll keep those
notifications on I'll still talk to them
like they feel like they they're
building no that's I mean I try to
engage in whatever it's just good to do
that just because whatever sometimes I
don't happen that often but every now
and then like a negative tweet catch me
and our response to the person and I'm
like what am i doing in there now it was
if I tell if I respond so negative like
what the [ __ ] in and out
response like 10 people that was showing
love it drown them out no not to drown
them out but just to be this is where
the attention should be focused but you
got to realize these people that are
hating they aren't really haters and I
know because I used to do it myself
so this is how you throw yeah I do it
I'm Beyonce like I go and Beyonce's page
and I'd be like [ __ ] you have a no no
this is like a year ago two years ago
two years ago yeah we all had a big
following I was still lit I still be
hating on Taylor Swift sometimes we're
just sorry guys okay yes I'll be like I
say I said that to be honest I say [ __ ]
you'll never amount to nothing and then
makers would click on they click on my
they would click on my page they'd be
playing oh oh this guy's funny and then
I get a spot like that oh really yes I'm
scared of social media but I love
Beyonce I love Beyonce
yeah but yet I got to get my I gotta get
I got to get poppin to like when she had
the kids I still be doing stuff like she
said something like oh it's been a month
since uh they been born if you want
Beyonce's page right now u see my
comment they said oh I didn't even know
they were born I must have missed the
tweet hey it wasn't a big hate but you
know it was enough hater so they click
on the name and be like oh who is this
guy yeah it's a thing with Instagram now
- yep if somebody has a lot of followers
if you go they only show three comments
on somebody page so his comment will
probably show up and they got it and she
got like 6 million likes on our picture
so depending on how many followers you
have it will make it a prominent that's
free fans
free fans let's go Beyonce just donating
fans there you go back so you go back
man we be trolling that's how it's going
yeah :
that's how it's going : ah trollin
trollin trollin ah ah yeah tell me when
that's roll rolling tell me when it's
wrong tell me when the troll
I mean look tell me what's wrong cash
money
it'll be okay are you making yeah yeah
hi um I'm focus man
tilt out the holler at me man Oh mr.
Brock
I like that once the rock is right that
works with and yeah Scoob rock yep yeah
so I took all these rapper ad-libs and I
just put them all in this [ __ ] boy
listen respect on my name one day you're
gonna get sued
uh-uh I don't think so it's a sample
it's just that whoa although we'll be
like you know what we went back into
that episode and we just cut that part
out cuz it was a very imprecise with the
sister where you can go back in episode
and edit it
sure sure Freddy Barangay on life of
Pablo he was making changes and
reuploading this [ __ ] man oh yeah you
don't reverse it yeah rematch on father
stretch my hands it was like different
[ __ ] with the vocals that's not fair
what's he turning the papers is greatest
this Kanye
he's like the Kanye changed the game
like that he took his table visitor
that's what happened was [ __ ] invisible
right you couldn't come in in my ear
right Britney CD back haha
brain reasonable doubt back in I have a
regretful barn
hahaha what's up you doing a video a
week yep
show you what else is poppin Brighton
movies writing [ __ ] Yeah right in raps
writing raps umm yeah I'm actually going
to do a comedy album music comedy album
take it on take it on the road okay
incorporated with my stand-up um so yeah
I've been working on that for a while
batch one thing we've talked about this
yes
one thing I respect about you is that uh
you have a huge following and if you
wanted to Couture your own right and two
big venues have fun but you chose to
open for joy koi for terrible money uh
yeah that's uh that's I think that shows
that you want to really work at stand-up
versus private hunt also shows you have
financial security coming in from
ah-ha-ha-ha yes yeah but no I think
that's what I mean you know I think a
lot of people use situation would you
know take the you know twenty five
thirty thousand dollar nights and just
write it and you know but you decided to
just really work and go into you know
opening for joy koi was a fun of crowded
not necessarily that's not your base
yeah yeah that's what I love about it
like opening for Joe it's like it's a
whole different demographic most people
have no idea who I am so I get an honest
reaction
my jokes yeah and it's made me so much
better as a stand-up and it's just it's
just this there's not there's not the
pressure of having to do everything
perfect where I can like fail and then
learn from the mistakes that I've made
you know and that's what I that's what
that's what makes me even love the craft
more because now I know how to go
onstage and before I couldn't do this
but I can go on the stage and just tell
a new joke at the very beginning right
and and it's like it breaks it down and
lets you see how it's not it's not easy
but how how simple it can be and how you
can make you just make something
relatable to the audience and this is a
whole nother avenue of learn to doing
stand-up with with doing it in front of
people that have no idea who I am
versus when I do something in front of
people who know who I am they just laugh
at and just laughing you don't know if
you're actually being funny or not sure
you know so it's like and then you can
you can see where I can see where I can
take a joke where it's unbelievable or
where I could take the Dro where it's
truthful and it's still which one lands
better you know what I'm saying right so
and I've learned a lot of it it's like
the true stories hit the hardest
yeah for many people people can feel it
you not I mean
in the way that you I mean the way did
you say it they can take kind of all
their this sounds sounds real yeah maybe
a little exaggeration it sounds real
yeah of course so where do you feel like
where do you feel like you're at as far
as that trajectory of giving so where
you're going to start doing the king bat
shows King Ranch events so I got it I
got a good uh 15 like a solid 15 yeah
that I feel comfortable doing in front
of any crowd universally and I just want
to keep on building it to where I got I
say like an hour and ten so then I can
chop off learning to chop off and also
if I'm going to do my music in the set
as well then I can really chop off
thirty minutes and just have the rest
you know
I just interjected music with the
stand-up you have to incorporate video
stuff to Lin oh yeah I didn't think
about that
what how did I even look at the video
guy I didn't think about putting video
yeah one of my favorite ones you did was
when you um when you played the you play
the joke I know you recorded it yeah Wow
my old joke yeah yeah oh my gosh it's
genius it's really fun it's a fun way to
put in bring in the old material but not
have to really do it do it until just do
a part of it because a lot of the old
jokes that have are not who I am anymore
yeah it's not a part of my it doesn't
sound right me saying it doesn't sound
right really yeah my roommate is crazy
yeah and the fuzz you're rich hahahaha
you roommate bro what are you talking
about right story-driven these days yeah
they just later popping sure they just
make sure naturebox late
[Music]
train
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
later later
yeah if you like smacks your [ __ ] can a
weirdo
what type of weirdo I like smacks
everybody likes snacks so I'm not even
talking to anybody right now
Nate's box got great snacks so step your
snack game up stop being a weirdo don't
live life in a mediocre way no matter
what your income is snacks is where you
can truly live it up no matter what your
station in life so stop being a [ __ ]
step your snack game up go to
naturebox.com/tyler favorites are
almonds and some other [ __ ] naturebox
they got all types of snacks they
switched up the snacks all the time they
really care about this [ __ ] they care
about snacks water you will ever care
about snacks you will see right now you
can say you don't want nature box softer
and handsome Rambla fans 50% off your
first order
when you go to naturebox.com/tyler as
nature box.com slash rambo for 50% off
your first water naturebox.com/tyler
let's get some snacks
[Music]
I've noticed I asked some a couple of
the friends from New York that I started
with that I found success in YouTube
videos that have millions of subscribers
and what I've observed is that their
fans have like a different energy then
it's like a yeah hey like type of cuz
they it's so much because you give a lot
at you you constantly so what's your
weirdest crazy friend interaction man
that when people get drunk yeah oh yeah
I'm sure you sure you deal with it too
but like when they get drunk it's just
they feel like they did that your best
friend and if you're sober it's like get
the [ __ ] out of my face the sober is
yeah you know the plan it's just like he
just did the worst is when they when
they already recording before they even
say hi to you isn't that the word you
already see the snapchat red line going
in the circle note his without this
happened at the airport yesterday mm-hmm
bro woke up one adult employee walk upon
me and ask for a picture
mm-hmm I said yeah and then yo we all
here we're having birth not a picture
yeah haven't you often they have a lot
where they like I get that yeah I'm um
I'm I'm very I mean obviously I'm very
specific about words I do stand-up
comedy for a living on my life is words
yeah that is nice
what you asked me for you are talking
right now that's just not cool that's
not cool pictures and pictures ah oui
I'll give you I really what the [ __ ] are
you doing
yeah that's not you just those big
different you said that's it two seconds
ago bro that wasn't even a gap so that's
premeditated bullshitter E yeah you I'm
asking for a pizza but I would take a
nine second video yeah just a difference
in video and pics alone is like
comparing magazines the porno movies
something different ally for whole
nother world as long as there's not a
ebay person I love signing [ __ ] eBay
people sell it usually they I mean they
tried my [ __ ] is not I seen the prices
of my stuff goes or on eBay this isn't
that very I valued at all I don't have
anything I knew that song yeah it's just
but sometimes people outside of premiers
or certain [ __ ] they'll have used to be
able [ __ ] with six or seven [ __ ]
different headshots of you or from
different shows your own that's
laterally it's flattering but there's
also like nobody normal really has that
as a marker and pictures ready yeah and
so did when you press them on it they
get it was a guy in Omaha they get upset
that I called him an eBay no wonder that
from the very back of eight CDs got a
bunch of [ __ ] and on I just put a bail I
said I'm gonna sign it anyway just say
to me that it I I don't give a [ __ ] he
was no personal collection and then I
don't know what I was looking at online
I might have been bored he goes surfing
and [ __ ] and I saw yeah I tried to get
Hannibal the Sun in Omaha he was caught
he saw but he was kind of a dick you
know I signed Jesse allows you I
sometimes it was one of the things I got
into it yeah and you see those matter
people don't he said something about
people don't care about like black
artists don't this don't sell that much
of some weird [ __ ] man
we had as an eBay culture of [ __ ] but in
general I kind of reared up I like just
a sign [ __ ] just because it's a you can
make a see you can make your own [ __ ]
with a name on it next time so they can
only send it to James baby that's what
they say that's what eBay is say when
you say that your eBay they say you can
personalize it I don't cook
oh resume they have come back that
prepared though doesn't happen to me as
much as way more famous people but I've
been a couple times where I've been
weirded out by their timing I remember
one time I was doing a show with Aziz
and Nashville whoo coming from Bonnaroo
mm-hmm no no no yeah we're going I
forget whatever we borrow is where I met
you you mean about yeah yeah yeah we met
at money 14 yep [ __ ] that and uh window
at nighttime in that in that tent I
don't know one of those tents I owe in
the Colton actually yeah yeah yeah I do
remember that yeah I think I was [ __ ]
up will you film or something nah oh I
was I was working with Ford yeah okay I
remember that they got Bonneville is
live for that code they bought a root I
thought with a I like that they don't
just explicitly say that everybody's
[ __ ] up hey this is building it's just
cold yeah just there if you want to be
there ya know
you know we ain't gonna say none Lana
was smooth yo
how do you meant 29:29 I went to your
crib you terrible in 2k man up wait did
I beat you no no I didn't beat Josh no
no I mean we could do the we could do
the rematch I got twitch it out you
could Twitter later into it
I want to start twitching Twitter's when
you livestream yourself Dom oh yeah yeah
just people that make an incredible
living just being an extremely engaging
personality on switch yeah
just switch and just all talk [ __ ] about
[ __ ] the peons or whatever that's cool
because I love I love when I watch two
people play a game and the shit-talking
game is on point
yeah so entertainment no it's great
that's what I am actually where I want
to move my career in hey I can somehow
[ __ ] talk in the video games me and
Percy playing NBA 2k how cousin person
like my brother
you guys go man weeds at we've been
playing through cage since 2k7 or some
[ __ ] to K it's been years yeah it's a
rivalry another UFC to ban you know you
you play UFC I go I got Bo play I just
kick his ass home it's a bit uneven oh
yeah
isn't it uneven I get up like do I have
to leave this room [ __ ] this man you a
jacket I get a couple win button and the
worst part about the UFC [ __ ] the way
the reason it even came into place
because we was at inspired in Chicago
and he be playing baseball he plays
[ __ ] baseball all of them on a video
game
Oh lay space and for it's the most
amazing way he uses PlayStation 4 to
play they play a baseball game God it's
an amazing how is that fun this is so it
was one day well I'm just sitting at the
Kremlin the dream
the [ __ ] is baseball no I want to impose
nice and when is target postmates and I
ordered UFC and second controller
hahaha and even tell me
so it's chilling at the crib and I'm
still playing baseball I'm in the zone
and I just hear dingdong what the [ __ ]
you little [ __ ] here I go I also open
the door is a [ __ ] guy with a target
bag I'm gonna control Mike what the [ __ ]
Hannibal what is this you think I got
UFC in a controlled a bleep idiot play
us boy damn yeah yeah and then I
proceeded to whup his ass and yeah he
probably had a
90% what you you fighting
well I train martial arts oh well but
that's not why when I have better the
games oh yeah just better with time and
you know I'm good at fighting games just
naturally except for street fighter
street fighters too intense for me
mmm Mortal Kombat mo combat every woman
has a mark on street fighters weirdo cuz
like it's like Milla frames so it's like
you like you're off by like it you slip
on the button for saying you get your
ass what like it's super intense oh wow
like the Japanese versions mm-hmm if you
go to arcades in Japan they're lower and
you sit down and play what that's how
intense it is like you have to sit down
and play because it's just close to the
height no it's just because people
that's how focused they are on playing
street fighter like it's a very focused
game it's so fast and like you just got
it you got to sit down and you got to
really go and you can't just have the
controls and be like yeah this let's go
you know you can't stop over there it's
too competitive
Japanese Tokyo arcade culture dog is
real I've only been there once but it's
just a different it's not the same is
it's a lifestyle
you're not running games man it's like
real little a real it's like that's a
happy hour is the arcade and sit with
lots of them is lots of loot gambling
[ __ ] gaming is like very serious to the
Japanese culture Wow rambling it's a lot
of specific weird [ __ ] they get our
cafes DIY our cafe oh yeah I'm going to
go out to a place and eat sandwiches and
have a drink and hang out without
hanging out at our fetch yes yes what's
the what's the business goal man cuz you
got the offices you're producing your
content oh I have a several question yes
it's actually you know hopefully I
remember them because I'm about I'm not
saying oh please the kilos in but I'm
still Co here and hit me up if you need
beats selling everything like that I got
these two things um not that one but I
write I got beats company okay okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so you get your office's batch
enterprises yes you bought some
expensive as cameras yes
you bought the cameras a hundred and
seventy thousand dollar camera
what of cameras are each each sees what
yeah with the lenses 177 everything
combined I can shoot transformers five
sixes away shows high level are you in a
seven digits for your production oh yeah
yeah I'll sign explain some he loses
batch girls hobby I'll be honest oh my
god God we were interviewing this kid um
so you yeah you wanna the movie that I'm
shooting in Atlanta now mmm-hmm was a
new line Warner Brothers production but
we're partially shooting at Tyler Perry
studios oh yeah I thought was shooting
that's where he's at
yeah weird using his offices and should
be paying him money
they got him they're paying him money
sir yeah yeah that's that's that's what
I want to do yeah um it's a I produced a
show for Kevin Hart for his new network
called them the laugh-out-loud Network
and that's kind of like my steps into
the production game with right without
producing stuff that so I produced the
show and I directed in it and I'm not
acting in it because I wanted to step
out
I did that so I can get my Tyler Perry
on yeah um so that show comes out August
3rd check it out
not and what a call okay it's called
dead house that out and it's about you
and Michelle real real world/road rules
back in the day of course yes that is I
wanted to be on real world before I knew
that I wanted I'm stand-up yet the firt
were the first commercial I saw a real
world I was like I wanna I should do
that
I feel really like I could best it was
something anyone I could be in a house
yeah yeah I didn't know anything about
staying wanted to stand up with real
world the first promo for it I'm gonna
be in my room and it touches me so yeah
the show was like that but it's about
five zombies and one human living in a
house okay
and it's in a world where zombies and
humans can so it's play like full
reality yeah yeah yeah rally style and
yeah zombies like can have coverage they
can have confidence yeah they're just
dead but are they trying to eat them
update they still want to eat humans but
they're at the level that they notice is
not right yeah they know it's so there's
like there's like a route there's a
route where you know what goodbye human
body parts and go eat like human heads
also kind of yeah so you can like yeah
yeah my methadone so you predict you
directed or you just produce all I
produce and directed so it's a produced
by batch enterprises directed by king
batch yeah and uh so yeah I did that and
you know the movies that I do like the
indie movies that I do executive produce
on those as well just to get my producer
name up in these streets you're a [ __ ]
powerhouse dude respect man yeah respect
so what's your what's the directed style
do you have after you tell me yours I'll
tell you a couple tricks that I've like
this so people because you have any
little directs and tricks to get a good
performance out of money
Oh Oh tricks what being an actor I just
know how to talk to actors and
and I know what not to say to actors you
know I got to say that like the line
readings like don't you hate when it
diverges yeah
you say it like a hey what's up how you
doing instead of like giving you like
the one word where it's just and then
they keep talking and then once you say
all right I got it once and then they
keep telling you how to do it and it's
like so you as an actor is kind of like
a little embarrassing just looking
around as the director is telling you
how to act you know well that's what
that's one thing I think as far as being
on a movie for a long time mm-hmm I
don't like about acting is in general I
don't feel like my own [ __ ] well if I
was like they're ready for you go put
the makeup off go getting clothes go eat
go over here stand like you feel like
I'm like I'm on am I gonna pop it yeah
yeah I got home you know I mean pushed
around I just didn't like I don't think
my temperament is especially for a long
silence I'm just doing a couple days
yeah it finds Cammie but for two months
just being isn't that for me man is that
I just like kind of fell into the world
I didn't choose the world have you
folded it all yet like [ __ ] this no no
no no you fold is just a general is work
just keep it in this work and you
realize that everybody else is also
working and be respected everybody's
saying they telling Will Smith to do
that depends on the director though no
they took no no it's not about the movie
situation Oh general Oh like the time in
the schedule just the whole get here
stand here do that and it but you have
to those or US production yeah it's the
whole team yeah it's the whole team and
uh so yeah it's just I like the finished
product the finished product is the part
but the whole this the I mean TV is
different and I YouTube video stuff is
different because it's a quicker process
but movie [ __ ] is like what do what's
going on what is the [ __ ]
is happening the ways been time I sat in
the trailer for five hours and they went
out and then we just and did full
wardrobe makeup and then just we did
some it was just my hands like turning a
lot that's a wrap on Hannah me what the
[ __ ] I got these clothes on for ya shot
my hand I feel like that I kept the coke
it was actually a day where I needed to
do a lot of editing on it if that's how
Tony you know that I'm bored on the
movie set yeah we're gonna finish your
work well no cause yeah I'll sit in
right meticulous I'll sit in like
meticulous as note right there you cut
that in cut that out put that in their
faces in right now I'm just a trailer
for four hours and so we're about to
tighten up over here and always I
respond are you a hetero Bo not just
bored that's bored and now focusing on
the stuff I actually like to do yeah
here's a move I like that uh directors
have done where they'll tell the other
actor to do some [ __ ] Oh randomly and I
don't know what they doing yeah that's a
fun move that's the best yeah that's a
comedian is good for us yeah if you if
you don't do improv it's the worst cuz
then you they'll freeze up like wait no
no no no it's just that's not his line
or they look at you like why are you
embarrassing me we're doing yeah but
yeah I did a movie like that with the do
you know make G director he did like
Terminator yeah so I did a movie uh it's
called the babysitter comes out in
October check it out or November one of
those months but um but yeah he tells
that he tells the actors to like throw
stuff at me that's not in the script and
I'll go with it right this is the best
like you know cuz that's what to me
that's what acting is about it's about
being present in the moment and that's
how you get the best responses right you
know yeah those are not a couple
directors throw that at me no no all
right I see you
take like I have a second okay I see
what you're doing it isn't daddy you
know planet I'll do that luck because it
seems like he's got that kind of vibe
I'm not sure I haven't I haven't worked
with a baton has set before Abbott I'll
helped with the Edinburgh special that I
did for Netflix he put up half the money
but he just helped his company did the
editing and everything it's just it's
just his movies but he doesn't he does
do some improv I did a movie with any TV
show an episode with Joe Swanberg yeah
Swami Chicago yeah Joe you know his
director style right knows no script
just now trying to tell you to say yeah
so we did that show called easy it's on
Netflix did you do see the one amazing
one you just sees one no [ __ ] that's an
unscripted show yeah oh I didn't know
that you know how he did it was uh you
just have the outline and we're we don't
forty minute takes one take us 40
minutes
all improv and it was like and when I'm
third take you like alright here we go
again but it's I get the best actor yeah
and that's also you great usage of time
in recorded yeah weird of you sitting
around trail area and Swanberg Jake
Johnson yes in a new girl he's in his
movie I'm working on he works with
Swampert yeah they keep it moving this
movie the movie they shot together
it's a Netflix movie they shot I forget
the name now cuz but it's about a
gambler but they cited in 17 days oh
sure
oh my god 17 days and that alright
that's how what is if I want to keep
doing movies I want to shoot them in 17
days cuz you got you got digital now so
it's like man 7 you know running out of
ssgt shooting just keep he got a good SS
and they trust him like that that
Netflix so he didn't have to pitch it to
him they just gave him the money
really yeah he didn't give him I didn't
give them out what's up loading you in
on that I watch most of it's a woman
Marc Marc Maron okay yeah and uh Emily
is that like right at 3 7 episode of
something it's the one right after that
it's I think I think it's episode six or
five one of those I just Joe is so
dedicated to shooting in Chicago he just
figures out what how about we just bring
about a guy in Chicago yeah that's dope
you know what do I do you guys know the
process of Curb Your Enthusiasm because
it's a way in that same way right and
it's that vibe that Curb Your Enthusiasm
is one of my favorite shows because of
that it's so loose and you could tell
that they like just kind of the don't
thing yeah I love curvy enthusiasm you
know new season about to come out - yeah
man are they still going strong
well there was they put the kibosh on it
but then they were like [ __ ] it we're
gonna bring it back for one more season
yeah one here twist like full house
let's hear the twist Joe Swanberg just
wanted to s I you while we were there
are you for real Danny on it was a six
for easy integration I think that's
right I think graduated we talked 2003
oh [ __ ] with the same College ISM didn't
run so did you do anybody student films
while you were in college
hell yeah yeah mm-hmm tapes that's all
that's all learn how to direct really
mm-hmm I think I think some of this time
are you - oh [ __ ] they're bad everybody
lives in check out bad student films I
love those the Google works but if
you're a real internet sleuth you can
find them bats where'd you go to school
it not saying oh we can find that out we
know where you went to Florida State
Florida I thought so Florida State Tyler
has a yeah that's a that's a party
school party school but also I imagine
just uh for the city an interesting
dynamic to go to school in cuz you got
family you right across the street yeah
my brother with the family oh yeah and
90s he's oh okay when there was when
there was criminal activity still
probably criminal activity is it not as
much my brother was down there when he
was either oh just kill good alpha okay
I was a Sigma you a Sigma uh-huh you
didn't strike me as a fraternity person
I know I'm charming cash money
no yeah mistake one yeah mm-hmm and my
sisters are data ah yeah yeah the y'all
do little weird steps with each other
sums with each other
haha there was eight of those uh yeah
every I live like I don't know what
isn't in the group and the right hand
brother answers the shaking money to go
brother and sister we're working
together
Emily if Emily no we know we never steps
together well well it is always
different still time your time to do it
that's great though you saw your sister
handles the business yeah I've met her
she's she's on point yeah she gets it
done she gets the [ __ ] done she um she
was doing she was in school she did her
master's to be a CPA yeah she got a
license and I said [ __ ] that you're
working for me you're gonna make triple
the money you make it now I already
think she really makes money I think I
just she just lives life for free right
now I just give her what she wants
wait I don't mean you don't think you
don't think good you because like my
money is basically her money but I think
this is so when I when she gets married
that's how I might have to start paying
her like one because right now it's like
she lives in my house she eats she if
she wants to go on a trip she gets to go
on a trip and she wants a car or buy a
car but I guess when she moves out and
she has a husband and so I figure out a
salary yeah I gotta figure out something
get this dude out of here and if this
deuce who is this man
no you probably need to establish a
salary right right huh right now all
right before I think one day she'll turn
evil and just take everything I got like
those stories not just sister I don't
think so yes you see like a people but
you never know everybody says what
everybody I would like to I would like
to you know I mean if she do turn out to
good people to be good people I will be
I would want to be the one yeah that
said it yeah she seemed good man of
course right I said it
remember I said it only was there never
doubted it he looked me in the eye we
talked seemed very solid she seemed like
she cared about her she's worried about
[ __ ] in the office she was like we got
to get some [ __ ] colors in here but
then what happens when I send you that
text lay my sisters she uh she went to
Mexico I can't I can't get in contact
with it all my money's wiped out can I
borrow $500 and I [ __ ] if MOU that's it
I never not again and they're not
connecting with my cleaner dawg
they'll get this [ __ ] fixed bad to kill
my sister listen bro you wouldn't find
your sister and ask some questions you
went there bad Jesus is just you - yes -
yeah
mmm your mom she she know how to deal
with money right oh yeah she know into
the accounting firm she owns an
accounting firm see see man you know
what I need to drop my business managers
yeah business management and
entertainment as a hoax bro it is what
it sure is
are they inviting your money I'm
investing but I compared in the time of
business Oh my business manager I know
Sam but they have a lot of
high net-worth people in the business
and done well for people obviously what
I compared them to is like a big agency
no and possibly that they could be
compared to that but also this Airport
bottled water right what you mean
Airport bottle water more expensive this
is more like it's still water yeah was
more like you still get hydrated you
still get hydrated right but you don't
have to cause that much yeah
hahahahahaha truth or carnival water
yeah it's just there is that is this in
this
they created the space where you know
people that are new into money mm-hmm
you're the big introduced by the agent
so you go to this one is five percent
wide if I was it and so I think that's
outstanding
yeah is a sure we're saying we should
start a firm together meet you and your
sisters haha sorry
entertainment management firm at each
other buddy two and a half percent
already started it yes
this yep oh [ __ ] we got clients already
you know we can make money with up I'm
starting my own like Netflix good what
yeah nothing's going no I mean beast
yeah but it'll be hard to okay what's
the what's the model so the difference
the difference is it's going to be more
of like a YouTube platform go on at
first um we're going to produce high
quality videos so say for instance we
have you as a client right alright you
have your other partner a partner right
right that means they say you're in
charge of the stand up the villain right
stand-up specials so say you
create a model that you want to do or
it's like you'll find 10 comedians and
you give them 10-minute specials or
whatever right we'll pay for the
specials and then you structure it where
you have all your structured over the
stand-up comedy section so Netflix they
have the action the adventure the sci-fi
thriller the stand up section your if
you're a partner you're in charge of
that section where you have the
different lineups now each each stand-up
comic will have so say that say they
have ten ten minute specials yeah ten
ten minute specials they can have people
subscribe to them for a dollar ninety
nine subscribe to the stand-up comedy
section to the sectional to the
individual to the section to the
stand-up comedy section or they
subscribe to the whole platform whatever
the name is and then they can watch
whatever stand-up exclusive material so
if it's if it's you if you exclusive
material and that artist can make money
from the subscriptions or they can make
money from the ads that are being run
right so yeah you got in place yeah
we're going on now nice man you have to
cut this all you want nobody's stealing
your idea oh no they can't steal the
technologies to advance yeah well it is
an advertisement man anybody yeah can't
get it you know can't block the business
can do it can't block the business shut
up you make it any moves any business
moves I'm doing some real estate stuff
okay
I got a building in Chicago I ever being
booted out oh really
yeah a whole building are just a unit
whole building three units Hotel
Hannibal is that what it's called
no it doesn't have a name and now you
just kind of what you just said is that
what it's called
made me feel like it needs a name even
though it doesn't at all but now I'm
like I've never seen a building without
a name it's just a three is a three unit
apart I'm you know I'm like how do you
ever
in a building without a name apartment
buildings just like a part but like you
talking like a big building like this
then apartment building without a name
it's a three but we've seen some mmm
without names mm-hmm but that doesn't
mean that this one shall go unnamed
because your place your last part
Tony's last apartment was a crazy dope
was it a lobster was just a really high
ceilings and it was caught what you know
Hollis yeah I call the trim Manor
yeah those but what about double H the
rates or hotel hotel Hannibal something
with H and H I can't put my name in it
just because is everyone being so I have
another fake name maybe two people when
I'm bringing people because I when I
when units are open when I'm back in
town I block out but it's nice it's the
bird's nest the bird's nest I like that
the perverseness burglary less though
the bird's nest
it's something I feel like that's where
you only go to have sexual intercourse
exactly so be alert don't call it the
bat game because that's just
drug-related but you know what I gotta
be honest I feel when I go is the first
thing I've owned when I go in there
mm-hmm
it feels good and also when is when I'm
standing one of the units and the other
to argue PI by strangers and I see the
lights off yeah all right that's it
that's great
I feel good yeah have you seen the movie
the founder no I don't know I saw some
of it the McDonald's ooh some of it I
was on a plane and then I yeah I had I
would have it that's how you make money
he are you by the property by the land
all right everybody listen about to be
filthy rich if they do this you buy the
land every everything is turning into a
goddamn jay-z album man you know funny
well mother gets hurt for for animal we
get you back to the front oh sorry
Robert but for the very poor football
one of my buddies hit me up y'all trying
to get into stocks now yeah and then I
had to send him screenshots of stocks
from my early last year that I was
getting into that have doubled now you
know Yugi got me and I look at our text
messages mm-hmm this [ __ ] price line is
double in price now this [ __ ] this other
[ __ ] that I sent you and you already
invested in those I'm in it
mmm yeah and so it was just funny I let
guess I got around next time
ha ha ha age today but probably the
founder son yes oh baby what the movies
about is he brought that he bought the
land and he builds a McDonald's on top
of it and he made them pay them pay him
rent and he weighed about the one with
Michael Keaton ooh yep that's that one
okay he did it all across the u.s. I
want to buy land and Mars
okay now you doing too much he's in Mars
you know it can't you buy land and Mars
is that is that during what I'll eat
much how're you gonna buy land on Mars
when Mars doesn't even have water that's
a strong point bats
oh yo check it yo oh yeah you want to
buy land on the planet called Mars
check it say the plant is too far what
you wanna do you got Lynn in California
Phil and I'm not trying to bore you
yeah get the land from your parents or
they just don't understand give it to
your boy back cuz he's a man ah the man
with the plan
give me that money
I'll flip it real quick you need to have
money don't suck my dick
whoa that took a turn went to the
bathroom didn't burn yes but I just took
a [ __ ] willing it up light a match real
quick like a match a cig goes away it
has a parcel way it turns a sense away
yes just amazing kiddo Noah's power yeah
we drunk at the Papa Kagawa ain't not we
I don't want to includes out I've been
drinking
y'all haven't at all it has to be silly
with Tony trim King bets up in this
terrible hotel yo everything in got a
rhyme nope something then is one time
yet chilling in downtown a lap nobody
used to want to be down head and cities
Oh
fruity loop this [ __ ] so crazy with the
fruity look yeah I ate some chips that
want some presses but he said no [ __ ]
well my friends so bad you don't share
where my pretzels that you don't care
hey hey I was jumping in on the hype man
[ __ ] but I interrupt it and now is this
all on me yeah
ain't no drums as HBA ad-lib coming in
[ __ ] from Tony trip yes yo I hate this
hotel so much is I struggle to keep it
rhythmically how much I didn't host
there I really hate it but I'm gonna try
to stay on the beat and not go on the
redness it just makes me pants buckle of
my and we're gonna goddamn [ __ ] yeah
others blames funders blames fathers
away this [ __ ] sucks
[ __ ] this place your they bout to bring
to my yelp review writing career yeah
good career new career yupper real
career can I write and say it and that's
have you ever written the up of you
never never never wrote one is that is
that a hobby people do obviously as well
you get paid can you get paid I think
sometimes people get benefits I've
written one yelp review but mm-hmm I use
yelp review as a resource all the time
is I'm sure you do yeah but it's like
Ryan tomatoes sometimes you can't trust
it
you never rational Yelper that did great
what yeah like if I paid you deal
I don't think exactly such thing as a
professional yep I think if people maybe
occasionally get a free dinner if
they'll of somebody that right thing
maybe it's a non-existent job but if it
wasn't you could create the job I could
create the child for a lot of jobs don't
exist yet but you again can't you get a
strong following on you open and uh
right if you get like a strong follow
and get a hell of followers can people
like I [ __ ] with Tony trims reviews
because he is Oh point but I don't know
if that's I I should start your own
website if that's the case gotta get
your own yeah gotta get your oh oh yeah
picture only known the only gotta get
your own and you bonus yeah I got my own
car been my soul there yeah then I kept
the profit you know invention I will not
stop it yeah you got to own it Tony you
gotta own it
come on it with me yeah yep yeah this
feels like you know this feel like this
is like Schoolhouse Rock before grown up
reaching hahahahahaha where education
and I we touch yeah mmm oh that's a drug
that's a sauce like you do that whoa
yeah baby oh this be kicking it in la
epital Figaro yellow up in the
convertible I just ate a zero ball a
gerbil eight de turbo can you fry sight
observables too cute the front they know
that like what to fry just in general
it's not a regular automatic please stop
this round real quick so we can discuss
this lady stop the beat because you want
to talk about eating gerbils yeah right
now why is this a dot of years because I
like I said convertible and in that I
had suffered only thing I come around
with durable which is not a word but
gerbil is then I thought about why don't
we eat gerbils ah eyes are too close to
rat had no culturally we don't other my
mother Venus would you eat it if would
you eat it and you eat it I feel like
you need a pet dog like I want what
here's a question I have for you ok what
I eat it I won't
I want this answer yes ring away but I
will ask you what's the garnish what
what is it was the garnish around it the
gerbil why does it even matter
what the [ __ ] you mean why don't matter
okay I'll guess intention is everything
we know this what is the whole person
what's your favorite what's your
favorite animal my favorite and I would
like to have it's a pet and I as a
pepper seed man what's your favorite
analyze a pen okay here's well I can't
cuz I don't have any pets and I haven't
had a pet for a long time so I can't
answer that question so I'll you ask me
what my favorite animal you'd it's the
cutest bunch of different kind of
my favorite cartoon animal is my
favorite animal in the zoo my favorite
animal to see in real life and favorite
animal is in real life bigger animal to
feel real life well that's so the pet
question is that's a that's a good
question yeah but this if you don't have
a pet it isn't what you like as a pet
favorite animal to see in real life okay
no matter what I say is your follow
question we know animals know that I
follow okay okay so I was one I like to
get ahead of stuff okay okay I just my
personal media training I was a this is
learning from experience I uh my
favorite animal to see a cool dog and a
bunny and a bunny cool it was a bunny we
wearing what's what's that bunny the odd
that he used the fur from it's not a
bunny but uh hair no it starts with a c
a it's got the softest fur so chela
chinchilla chinchilla you like
chinchillas I mean I don't think I kick
the word Zilla before okay who's kicked
normals really so what if you had don't
listen to us the cute is the cutest dog
okay I'm talking you get you can just
see the human features in it work it
looked like a baby
thank you now say I Friday's baby mm-hmm
and I put your favorite seasonings
around it would you serve it to your
family members and not tell them that it
used to be a cute little rock and eat
with them with some rice I get idea what
you're doing
and see what Moses you're trying to
appeal to but I feel like it's a flawed
analogy because we don't be know
[Laughter]
I see that okay I feel like even which I
love chicken and burgers and bacon
mm-hmm but if I knew these pigs in the
you take it I'll be like what the [ __ ]
that's about to be bacon oh you really
like the coolest however right and then
you'll be like I'm not eating that
burden to the great magma is I think
it's about the personal I mean if you
had uh if you're somebody to eat meat
obviously a vegetarian vegan then your
whole angle and relationship with the
situation is different but for me you
know some people I wouldn't eat a dog
but you know yeah got my dog cuz you
take like my dog I think I added dog
before buy in China uh like real talk in
Korean so every member of my family from
Korea has eaten dogs many times and I've
ate paper as rice in China because they
do that too
no yep no wait actual paper from trees
not yeah paper they substitute it it's
cheap away well I've eaten foil as
burritos haha how do you see the show uh
what what the hell the documentary did
you have with people Zoey you see the
thing with that show is if I ruin you it
you don't even want to eat food anymore
like just all food is out even
pescetarian they find they find
something wrong with everything I just
give them strong enough to power through
oh I watched a while eating chicken yeah
but it's a it's very some girl that I
met years ago yeah that knows I have
asthma I think we went we were at some
festival in 2011 and I think it was fun
we were hanging out and we ended up
taking one of those old people carts in
a Walmart in upstate New York
yeah I need to go get an inhale and we
did that so she just remembers that I
have asthma so she writes me every now
and then oh uh and she just wrote me we
write every now and then Oh
past six years or so she says said a
animal need to watch what the help you
going to stop eating dairy so it helps
with your ass like whoa yeah but it does
the documentary is so overwhelming that
you just give up and you go back to
eating everything this is what I do yeah
because after you like I just work out
work out because it goes so it says with
you eating eggs it's a it's equivalent
to smoking 5 cigarettes yeah
what yep [ __ ] that [ __ ]
okay legit matter the book [ __ ] that I
don't accept that
how many eggs what what egg per five
cigarette one my egg is 500 [ __ ] the
cholesterol on the Fed knowledge hey
[ __ ] that documentary
hey yeah [ __ ] that documents array [ __ ]
it [ __ ] what hey can be no five
cigarettes I don't give a [ __ ] about the
head okay that's is insane what what you
think go no more pocket I love a nice
cigarette green eggs and ham this flavor
about my bye to this home in case you
didn't know what the [ __ ] oh no no one
help oh [ __ ]
I'm in the pocket on this [ __ ]
beat [ __ ] back to the message
[ __ ] that [ __ ] cigarettes also exist
don't [ __ ] omelets boil deviled eggs
I rub into the soil oh oh
magda ham yeah and I put it in the pan
pry it up because I eat it like a man ah
hey yo check it
Eddie eggs in my belly belly watch the
telly side documentary that said it's
bad I said [ __ ] you you're not my dad
imma eat my eggs
I'm an anything go to bed then I wake up
and do it again I like my eggs [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you Rosie's good grace edges both
days on good grades heads both legs
gracious balls eggs gracious eggs Bolton
and this gracious ex boldface eggs egg
egg good gracious eggs is both a good
crisis eggs both places and good
gracious exportation good grace eggs
both a nest egg crate suspense Bolton's
eggs good gracious exportation eggs
exposes yeah yeah laughs all right
that's settled all the passion for eggs
yeah we figured out all the vegans that
we figured that out subscribe actually
you can try and veganism on for the past
three days
well let me tell you one thing right now
yeah we're gonna made a significant
difference in my BMS solid more solid
and intro and down in the BM like crazy
it's it's it was it like well control
I'm taking faster dumps controlled
control and tells regular man she's
always answer them so you admit that
when you took that whiz it was really a
dump
no I don't know why the hesitation I
know I just take I just took a long ways
and then you know straighten myself out
and say that cause Iggy Langley
[ __ ] a lot dudes don't lie
about [ __ ] didn't you know then we'd be
like
yeah I said yeah I was there yeah just
it was gross son like it's like a [ __ ]
yeah I believe because he left the
bathroom open he would disrespect us
like dude talk about [ __ ] [ __ ] is almost
the same as having sex yeah yeah no
matter you and blue it was crazy
whatever one of the 20 minutes
how Hannibal be treating a [ __ ] like
he'd be blessing the joint it's like I'm
about to hook this place up well for one
I think is the I'm not a religious
person and I think taking crazy shits
confirms my atheism really yeah how
where when I'm late
say I've had a crazy week and is one day
where I'm you know taking six hits
within a couple hours six yeah that's
what happens when you take back care of
yourself okay I've added care of
yourself and he takes back here yourself
Andrew and yeah since I'm in LA
let me sit on the toilet and say if if
there was a God he wouldn't let this
happen to me why not but he's probably
making it happen to you because you
don't believe in him so he's making you
spend the whole enjoyable day on the
toilet well yeah that's a good
counterpoint no no no no because I
believe in me you will be [ __ ] all
day all day you seen bricks
listen you yeah [ __ ] theists heathens
can try to undermine my thoughts with
you goddamn sound bites as much as you
want here believe believe but when the
devil comes when the devil comes
everybody will know yes where is this
podcast gone yes sir
were you in this is the end were you in
that movie
no oh yeah think about it for as I get
better there were a lot of completion
I don't know I was in another look in
the skies like wait a minute no there
was ease not now and he was even in that
movie there's a guy and they all hate
this ya know so yeah I don't think a
real guy will be they let us [ __ ] like
that and I also I don't think a good
benevolent God would be that petty like
y'all don't believe in me I think a real
[ __ ] will respect some
skepticism no sense if you expect my
[ __ ] blindly believe people like yo I
respect that you ain't just gonna [ __ ]
accept that I'm some [ __ ] omnipresent
don't [ __ ] I'm just someone
[ __ ] controlling I respected you
question is should wait a while another
city this is weird as [ __ ] son I
respected you question that [ __ ]
you know I don't think I would act like
oh god from New York but the gods from
wherever ah is or wherever we you know
whatever reason you're able to do the
best best access
oh that yes thanks for coming through
man thanks for having me
good luck with everything thank you I
appreciate it you inspired me to get my
business together we gonna do it I'm
opposed to I post more videos just
because I know you post a lot kind of
like as you know people yeah and I'm
about to start writing [ __ ] on the
peoples Tonto and I took that you gave
us about trolling one light Litro low
light like a famous you got to do light
if you're not famous you go in I'm about
to go ham because I was like I like
throw I'm about to go ham cannibal gotta
go light I'm gonna like I said even in
real life you guys go light Huckabee you
say some hearts if he was he was
terrible I was just kidding yeah I'm
going ham go ahead I'm going ham Tony
said I'll sit follow Tony's Ramona
socials to his new journey how many
fathers you got right now I got RAM
I'm like
four thousand yeah you gotta go pretty
hard I gotta go home you got it like I
got it I got some out yeah death threats
you only [ __ ] your mama ain't [ __ ] why'd
you go to the most Demaret live yeah
along with a certain respect Tony oh you
just best knew that Messina know what
yeah absolutely that infest cell phone
that yet imagine to learn I just met her
I'm ready everybody
leader says really you don't even know
which ones which was which I just gotta
go here and then says imagine teenagers
which we had the stuff they had yeah
this amount of teenagers but now with
access so the toys you wish you are you
were rich I had access to every yeah
access to everything your mom own
accounting firm I like I like this one
from a past episode somebody just said
the dark wet but it just sounds good
your dark where we could put a big dark
when it is hot well that's good I can go
to dark room
yeah well here's Hannibal other webs and
aqua dark where the dark where the dark
words are kind of dark weird awkward
awkward awkward awkward awkward dark
will about this bison to the night and I
bite around the booty as you said she
want to fight us you're right
bites in the bed bug bites then we get
instead of the night and it's get it to
the oh I thought the beat was not a drop
oh yeah because that is Oh
I'll cut like a [ __ ] EDM beat red
after got a drop
yeah that's the sound wave it yeah wait
yeah yeah bad just hold it out what some
wrong oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah what you wanna do
it's the close of the show now closing
man yep had a blast now play you whip
everybody came to the show 10 minutes
late resetting this action on the day I
was like sure let's go I gotta do this
podcast first then we will go out and
get some sushi sushi sushi sushi so see
ya yeah some sushi she like fish I like
my fig you can suck it up real quick
yeah [ __ ] I took a perm whoa yeah fish
to dick yeah whoa what's up yeah King
bass you had to sit back up yo
I'll pick it up change the flow your boy
Batson I don't want to go but I gotta
kick around on a day to suck my dick my
dick my dick my dick my dick
ha ha she's sucking on my dick and she's
sucking on my dick
I will loosen it up I'm just kidding I
wanna introduce you to my family and
I'll take you to the beach and maybe you
can suck my dick apart
five I get yo getting bad Joe yes yo
that was a very polarizing applause
thank you thank you thank you for that
[Music]
[Music]